these words spake Jesus and lifted up
his eyes to heaven and said father the
hour is come glorify thy son that thy
son Also may glorify thee as thou has
given him Power Over All Flesh that he
should give eternal life to his many as
thou has given him and this is life
eternal that they might Know Thee the
only true God and Jesus Christ whom thou
has sent I have glorified thee on the
earth I have finished the work which
thou gavest me to do and now oh Father
glorify thou me with thine own self with
the glory which I had with thee before
the world was I have manifested thy name
unto the men which thou gavest me out of
the world World thine they were and thou
givest down me and they have kept Thy
word now they have known that all things
whatsoever thou has given me are of thee
for I have given unto them The Words
which thou givest me and they have
received them and have known surely that
I came out from thee and they have
believed that thou this send me God is
good all the time and all the
time Psalm 100 ver5 for the Lord is good
his Mercy is
Everlasting and his truth endureth to
all
generations all
generations as long as there is God
there will be truth because truth
ultimately is God Jesus said I am the
way the truth and the life 1 John 5:6
the Holy Ghost is truth Deuteronomy 32:4
God is truth he or she who lives
truthfully is a member of the family of
God and with at the risk of being not
very political you cannot live
truthfully unless you live in accordance
with thus sayth the Lord
amen you may live
decently but to live truthfully you must
live in accordance with the principles
of God's word happy Sabbath everyone
happy thank you very much for coming to
God's house to worship him we thank him
for freedom of worship that still exists
in this country and the operative word
is still because one day it will cease
according to Bible prophecy we will not
be able to do this do you understand
understand me m this is a privilege to
be
enjoyed while we have it it will come to
an end according to Bible prophecy those
of you who are not seventhday Adventists
may your hands you are not God bless you
God bless you anybody else God bless you
anybody else God bless you anybody else
you are not a seventh let me offer
special prayer for you Father in heaven
we have guests among us and we're always
delighted to have them in the name of
Jesus Christ who died for them bless
them Father in unexpected ways bless
them lavishly de God bless them
specifically father to such a degree
that your goodness to them will soften
their hearts towards you put a double
blessing on their children I pray and
father I extend this blessing to all
those online in the name of Jesus Christ
we pray let God's people say amen and
amen our subject for today what about
me or what about
you you can pick the one that fits based
upon where I am in the sermon what about
me
or what about
you in accordance with the lady who made
some comments earlier this
morning if you're not using one of these
what should you
do yes turn them off or throw them away
uh favor number two while I'm speaking
pray for me and say Lord put your words
in that man's mouth Jeremiah 1:9 then
the Lord put forth his hand and touched
my mouth and the Lord said unto me
behold I have put my words in thy mouth
and I want to speak God's words because
my words cannot save you favor number
three think Isaiah 1118 come now let us
do what Reon together sayth the Lord let
us pray dear
God I have come to ask for what I don't
deserve that's
Mercy have come de God because you're
the only one who can
help I have come because the blood of
your son alone can cleanse my
sins if I offended you they God forgive
me
please and do it quickly father now I
commit myself to you de God for the
presentation of this message possess me
de God my mind my memory my mouth my
whole physical
apparatus let every word I speak be from
you let me seek no glory but seek to
direct the glory to you bless all those
listening in this building and on line
put a double blessing on our visitors de
God and at the end of this message let
us know we've heard from you not from me
be merciful to those in Myanmar and
Thailand de God who are suffering from
that catastrophic earthquake many many
buried ah father bring them out bring
them out deliver them quickly de God I
pray and as these disasters strike let
us remember we're living in the last
days and to live our lives accordingly
thank you for the honor speak speaking
for you use me now I pray in Jesus name
let God's people say amen and amen go
with me to Matthew chapter 7 we shall
read verse
11 I read from the King James version of
the Bible if you have that version you
may read with me Matthew 7 reading verse
11 I want you to read microscopically I
have some questions for you when you
found it and you're ready say amen
amen if ye then being evil know how to
give good gifts unto your
children how much more shall your father
which is in heaven give good things to
them that ask him now let's read that
again if ye then being evil know how to
give good gifts unto your children how
much more shall your father which is in
heaven now we have two principles in
that verse two persons who are the two
persons or the two we have the two
persons
if you referring to
whom referring to whom read the verse
microscopically if ye then being evil
know to give good gifts unto your
children you is whom
parents read microscopically think if
you evil parents what is an evil person
parent or not someone who possesses what
kind of nature the Fallen nature whose
mind is described in the Bible as the
carnal mind is enmity against God for it
is not subject to the
neither indeed can be the heart of man
is deceitful above all things and
desperately wicked this is the mind and
Jesus said if you with that kind of
mind you love your children so much that
your love for them fights its way
through your corrupt
mind and identifies good
gifts how much
more shall your father now how does
Jesus describe the
parents evil how does he describe
God is that in the
verse look at the
verse how is God described in the
verse is that in the verse where it says
Father in
Heaven how are the parents
described evil how is God described
how is the character of the parents
described how is the character of God
described in the
verse is that what the verse
says well the verse doesn't say it but
it's not what the verse means
yes the verse tells us about God's
character by telling us about the
opposite are you with me and the
opposite is evil parents now is God a
parent yes or no yes we are his children
now if ye being evil know how to give
good gifts unto your children how much
more shall your father which is in
heaven who is
good is not written but you and I based
on reasoning must fill in come on the
[Music]
blanks he's
good now if a good God who has never
sinned who who is absolutely
perfect how much more will he give you
what is good for you if you ask now
let's put it in the context of our title
if your sinful parents know what's good
for
you what about
me did you have
breakfast what about me says God are you
with me
if sinful fathers and mothers know how
to get provide for their children what
about me and I am
sinless can I know how to provide for
you with all these government
Cuts or do you trust Social Security
more than you trust
me notice the expression how much more
God doesn't nickel and dime when he
blesses how much more shall your father
which is in heaven give good things to
them that
ask so God is saying what about me I can
take care of you let's stay in Matthew
with one chapter earlier Matthew 6 we'll
read from verse 25 what's our subject
what about me what about
you the depending on where I am in the
message do you have it what
chapter what
verse read it with me therefore what I
say unto you take no thought for your
life what you shall eat nor what you
shall drink nor yet for your body what
you shall put on now what do you
understand by take no thought is God
telling us don't think what is he
telling us not to don't
worry now we are in in a worrying phase
in this country we are in a worrying
phase in this world Greenland is in a
worrying phase are you with
me and Canada we may have 52 States
before you
blink we are in a worrying World Jesus
said therefore I say to you take no
thought for your life what you shall eat
or what you shall drink nor yet for your
body what you shall put on is not the
life more than meat and the body the
rammen next verse behold the fouls of
the air they saw not neither do they
reap nor gather into barns yet your
heavenly father Feth them finish the
verse are ye not much better than they
now in Matthew 7:11 Jesus says how much
more shall your father which is in
heaven give good things now Jesus says
are ye not much more or much better than
than they now we have the two principles
we have the birds and we have
you behold the fowls of the
air they so not neither do they reap nor
gather into barns yet your heavenly
father feeded
them what about
you if I feed birds
not made in my image if I feed birds for
whom Jesus Christ did not shed his blood
what's our subject what about
you I'll feed
you but without faith come on it's
impossible to please God and so in
Matthew 7:11 Jes the father said Jesus
says God is saying what about me your
evil parents know how to give what about
me me your sinless heavenly father I
know what's best for
you listen to my words I know I know
what's best for you you
don't is this mic
working you do not the Bible says we
don't know how to
pray if we could see the end from the
beginning we would change many
prayers are you with me especially
relationship prayers
we will change them and so Matthew 7:11
God says what about me I know how to
provide Matthew 6:25 Jesus says 626 you
of more value better than Birds what
about you I'll take care of
you let's go to Mark
5 the shortest gospel he was not one of
the 12 disciples it's 18 minutes after
12 when did I start
about five after H not so long ago okay
what book did I say what chapter we read
from verse one and may the god of Heaven
and Earth continue to possess my mind
and my mouth in Jesus name I pray amen
read with me and they came over unto the
other side of the sea into the country
of the gatherin and when he was come out
of the ship immediately they met him out
of the tombs a man with an unclean
Spirit who had his dwellings where among
the tombs neither can any man what bind
him nor not with chains no man could
bind him no not with chains because that
he had been often bound with Fetters and
the chains and the chains have been
plucked to Under by and the the fet
plucked to under the chains broken in
pieces and neither could any man tame
this man was
wild suffering possessed by the way
that's the condition Satan would like to
have all of us in but God is merciful
can you say amen for God if God removes
his restraining hand of the devil
ah and always Night and Day verse five
he was in the mountains and in the tombs
crying and cutting himself with stones
self-destruction that's the devil's aim
for you and me self-destruction under
his Direction
verse six but when he saw Jesus AAR off
he ran and worshiped him and cried with
a loud voice and said th what have I to
do with thee Jesus thou son of the most
high God I adure Thee by God finish the
verse that thou torment me not now
question for you did the man the demon
really ask a favor of
Jesus your yes was weak yeah
did he ask of did he make a request of
Jesus what was the request don't torment
me don't hurt
me don't you feel encouraged that demons
have to beg your savior don't hurt
me your savior intimidates the
devil you don't but your savior does are
you with me say amen for Jesus amen mhm
M torment me not he made a request he
asked a favor clearly from the context
Jesus granted him that favor did not
torment him we go on verse 9 verse 10
and he besought him much that he would
not send them away out of the country is
that a request he makes to
Jesus I have told you before always
speak with confidence even when you're
wrong
now did the demon make a second request
of Christ yes what did he say don't send
us away out of the country did Jesus
grant that request
yes let's go to 12 read with me and all
the Devils besought him saying send us
into sight that we may enter into them
read verse 13 and forth with Jesus gave
them leaves talk did they make a third
request of Jesus did he Grant it how
many requests did they make one do not
torment me two don't send us out of the
country three send us into the pigs
request one Jesus said yes request two
Jesus said yes request three Jesus said
yes Jesus gave requests or he answered
requests of demons what's our subject
what about
me I have requests
I'm not a demon I worship God I study
his word I'm not saying he's obligated
to me but he has told us come now let us
do what reason together he told me I am
of more value than Birds he told me he's
able to provide for me more than my
Earthly parents if God will grant favors
to Demons what's our subject what about
me I need some
favors I've got three children I lost my
job what about
me I'm looking down the barrel of a
divorce and I don't want to leave lose
my wife or husband what about me you
granted a request a demon what about
me you told me let's reason together I'm
reasoning demon says do this Jesus said
okay do that Jesus said okay do that
Jesus said okay
three I don't know how significant it is
but three is the Divine
number now here I
come well here come
you I'm your child a God I never said
I'm perfect I'm your child I acknowledge
you you granted
them what about
me my needs are greater than
them hell was prepared for them your
kingdom was prepared for me what about
me Jesus told me when I pray say our
father the demons can't say that what
about
me but go to Job chapter 1 Job
1 is 25 minutes after
12 God is good all the time and all the
time God is good do you love God all
right I believe you what book did I say
what chapter let's read from verse
six when you found it say Amen read with
me now there was a day when the sons of
God came to present themselves before
the Lord and Satan came also among them
mm the devil likes to frequent the
Gathering of God's
people because not everyone in church is
God's
people the people who said crucify him
were church
people the one who betrayed him was a
church person are you following
me those who persecuted the the
disciples were church
people and Satan came also among them
verse 7 and the Lord said unto Satan
whence comest thou
then Satan answered the Lord and said
from going to and fro in the earth and
from walking up and down in it and the
Lord said unto Satan hast thou
considered my servant job that there's
none like him in the earth a perfect and
an upright man one that fearth God and
estruth Evil God is bragging about job
to
Satan question for you can God brag to
Satan about you don't answer me wow yes
or me I'm not answering out love verse 9
then Satan answered the Lord and said do
job fear God for not Hast not Thou made
Read With Me Now a hedge about him and
about his house and about all that he ha
on every side Satan could not get to job
he was so faithful to God and so close
to God there's one thing to devil hates
that is the presence of God are you with
me let me say it again Satan hates the
presence of God when you frequent the
presence of God you create a problem for
the
devil and so Jesus says abide in me not
near me abide in
me Hast not Thou made a hedge about him
and about his house and about all that
he hath on every side thou Hast blessed
the work work of his hands and his
substance is increased in the land
now keep reading but put forth thy hand
now come on read with me and touch all
that he hath and he will curse thee to
thy face next verse says what and the
Lord said to Satan behold all that he
hath is in thine hand only upon himself
but not forth th wait a minute God said
he's in your hands so when we read put
forth thy hand now and touch all that he
have while Satan is really saying let me
get to
him so God grants the request ah you're
not
listening now we're not talking about
demons now we're talking about Satan are
you following me the chairman of the
Demonic board we're talking about Satan
and Satan says God I have a
request let me get to this man
and God said
okay nobody's
listening who is God's
enemy Satan Satan is God's enemy enemy
enemy enemy to the end degree this enemy
says grant me this favor and God said
yes not for Satan's benefit for God's
glory but he still said yes now what's
our subject what about me
I've been praying for 5
years for this or
that what about
me father look look at
me you granted favors to
Demons in Mark 5 three consecutive
favors long before that Satan made a
request you said yes
let's go to Job chapter
2 all right job 2 we read from verse one
those of you online I hope you're still
with us wherever you are may the Lord
bless you you may be worshiping
somewhere where there's no church may
the Lord bless you and really make his
presence felt with you where you are job
2 read from verse one what does the
Bible say again there was a day when the
sons of God came to present themselves
before the Lord and Satan came also
among them to present himself before the
Lord and the Lord said unto Satan whence
comest thou and Satan answered the Lord
and said from going to and fro in the
earth and from walking up and down in it
the Lord said unto Satan what hast thou
considered my servant job that there's
none like him in the earth a perfect and
an upright man one that feareth God and
estruth Evil now finish the verse and
still he does what he what hold this
fast his Integrity although thou movest
me against against him to destroy him
without a cause by the way God does not
destroy unless there's a
cause you didn't get
that God could not destroy job God said
I have no cause but you want me to
destroy him and I have no
cause you and I must so live we give God
no cause to destroy us are you following
me it is we who give God the
causes by pers
Disobedience Now read verse four nice
and loud and microscopically what does
that say and Satan answered the Lord and
said what skin for skin all that a man
hath will he give for his life keep
reading
but stretch do what read that again but
what put forth out thy hand and touch
his yes and his and he will curse thee
yes touch his bones and his flesh
our greatest need is
survival you touch that now and the Lord
said Satan what behold what he's in th
hand finish it but save his life now did
Satan make a request what was his
request let me touch
him not his shop him what did God say
behold he's in thy hand but save his
life no wait a minute that's twice
chapter one Satan said I have request
God said oh hey chapter 2 satan said I
want to do this God said go
ahead and our subject
is how can a demon and a devil so
quickly have a request granted and I am
a child of
God am I charging god with unfair
Behavior oh no the Lord is righteous in
all his his ways and holy in all his
works I'm simply saying based on the
reasoning of Jesus Christ if he then
being evil know how to give good gifts
unto your children how much more shall
your father which is in heaven give good
things to them that ask him well let's
extend that reasoning if God can give
requests and Grant requests to Demons
that make specific requests of him how
much more will God give requests to us
or answer our requests
and so we must go to God with boldness
but
humility and say father what shall we
say come on what shall we say what's our
subject what about
me I've been suffering with rum thought
out wrers for 20
years can hardly
walk what about
me demons have freedom to go all over
the world
they have no
arthritis what about
me I need some favors
granted I have a friend who's very
sick there are people in Thailand
Myanmar under tons and tons of rubble we
God as a church have a request deliver
some of them Father that's our request
we're not
demons my son ran off with friends that
are no good he got into drugs now he's
in prison I want his life turned around
father that's my request father let me
remind you that Jesus granted request
one request two request three please God
allow me to say what about
me what about
me I don't claim to be good father but I
claim to love
you I claim to love you to the best of
my human ability please God if you can
do that for demons with respect to
granting requests remember me little me
in my little corner but still your
child what about me and you said if evil
parents can give good gifts what about
you well father combin the two what
about you yes you can bless what about
me yes I need your blessing
and so today at
12:34 God looks down on us and he wants
us to come to
him with a boldness that is filled with
humility and say
father if you can do that for
them surely you can do that for
me that's not to say God is obligated it
is simply to say you said let us reason
together that's what you said
I'm
reasoning out of my desperation I'm
reasoning
father grant me this
favor grant me the request but beyond a
request for money saving a relationship
whatever else father I want victory over
sin can you say amen that's my numeral
owner that's my request I have a
weakness I want Victory de God grant me
that request God even more quickly than
you granted requests to Demons
how many of you will say father I'm your
child I have a burden I place it before
you answer me can I see your hand answer
me stand up with
me what about
me and God looks at us and says I take
care of birds what about you
God looks at us reminds us evil parents
know how to do what's right for their
children what about me I am a good
parent I'll take care of you I granted
request to Demons you may be assured if
I can do that for them I'll do much more
for you heads bowed eyes closed our
father in
Heaven thank you for your word if I
spoke badly forgive me if I was too hard
on your children forgive me dear God but
father remind us on the basis of your
word that cannot
fail we come to you and we say what
about us your
children spiritually father we're not
the Egyptians we're the
Israelites you sent plagues on the
Egyptians to deliver the Israelites
father now God we ask you to look into
our lives look at what we've been
praying for we've been agonizing look at
what has been causing us headache
heartache and sorrow
and I request to you father Deliver Us
from these burdens as we say to you with
respect what about me dear God watch
over
us answer our prayers according to your
will do all you can to keep us in your
bosom dear father with the force of love
and answer that person's prayer standing
in your presence answer that Father's
prayer that mother's prayer that
husband's wife's prayer prayer that
child's
prayer and hasten today Father when you
will come and restore this world to its
original Perfection and there will be no
demons no Devils no sickness no more
prayer requests because we shall speak
with you face to face bless us in Jesus
name I pray that all God's people say
amen and amen don't sit what will you
take from the message tell us quickly
raise your hand and tell us what will
you take from the message raise a
yes
notroy God does not destroy without
cause and it is we who give God the
cause in that sense we practice
self-destruction yes serve good we serve
a good
father I don't mean the one who lives in
your house the one who lives upstairs we
God bless the one in the house but we
serve a good
father and where is he Our Father in
Heaven somebody else
yes no matter what's going on in the
world remember those words father what
about me all these cuts and jobs what
about me and mine some
yes you answer the request of demons
what about me de God and I'm no demon
yes no
request no request is too big or too
small for God take it to him remember
what he said to Abraham in Genesis 18:14
is anything too hard for the Lord what
the answer no did I see your hand yes
Debbie it is God who says come to me and
tell me what about me come and tell me
that yes Brandon
come with humble boldness yes you don't
crawl to your Earthly father why are you
crawling to
me
yes say that
again oh yes it's a habit he has he
can't break it God is good even when
he's whipping us he is good yes sister
God is God is truth say it again God is
truth
and for a man or a woman to live
truthfully that person must live by
God's handbook for an upright life yes
in the
back we serve a God who answers prayers
yes or grants requests anybody else than
I now May the grace of our Lord Jesus
Christ and the love of God and The
Fellowship of the Holy Spirit be with us
now and forever more let God's people
say
amen and amen please be seated the
ushers will Usher you out at the right
time